and so i think the key to having a
morning routine and morning routines are
critical that's the problem with
achievers i think the the the journey of
your whole life
is figuring out how to truly
like and love yourself
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person but when you start your
day with a powerful routine that
inspires you like watching one of these
videos it can change your life so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee know that i believe in you
and get ready for a shot of espresso
from mel robbins
[Music]
here's the thing about morning routines
i think morning routine envy is a real
thing
and
i do believe that a lot of people lie
about their morning routines
i think lying about your morning routine
is a real thing i think pretending you
have the perfect morning routine is a
real thing
um
i'm
i'm about when i'm home i'm almost 80
in my morning routine i get it done
because it's super simple right so i
mean i think i need a simple one yes
and when i'm traveling
i almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses and so
i think the key to having a morning
routine and morning routines are
critical
because how you start your day
has a massive
proven impact on how your day turns out
there's one piece of research that i
think is really profound and this comes
from sean anchor i talked about this
yesterday but i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you um this too susie
if you consume three minutes just three
minutes of negative news
of negative television
of negative emails maybe stressful
emails from work or stressful texts from
friends
you have more than a 50 chance eight
hours later to say you had a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind
it literally sets your mind up to be on
the lookout for things going wrong
and so the reason why a morning routine
is is actually so important is because
number one
it determines what your priority for the
day is
and we also know based on research that
your mood in the morning
it impacts your productivity all day
long the most important part of a
morning routine is how you feel about
yourself it's the number one thing that
people do not pay attention to that
matters the most is how do you feel
about yourself when you're done your
morning routine nobody wakes up perfect
nobody wakes up full of energy yes ready
to go wrong i can't believe today is
another day what are they to be alive
i'm so grateful i like nobody nobody mel
robbins evan carmichael tony robbins
nobody
the difference between where most people
are at and the people who have success
is that they demand
that they show up and they create that
through the routines and the habits
which is your morning routine it's the
easiest way to just get started so you
go from being tired and having stuff in
your eyes and lines on your face and
rolling out of bed to then feeling
inspired motivated ready to take on the
day
how do you do that well
you have to find the thing that actually
makes you feel powerful inspired
motivated confident and ready to go and
most people
just go through the motions and i'm
talking to the achievers now most of
america most of the world doesn't have a
morning routine at all they fall into
their day they wake up like an accident
and they start falling to what other
people want them to do for the day like
most people wake up and just immediately
go to their phones see the crisis and
they're rushing off to go work on
somebody else's dream they wake up drive
to a job that they hate to work on
building somebody else's dream that's
most people you guys watching this
you're probably more on the achievers
side you probably have some kind of
morning routine you're probably doing
more than your friends and the people
around you
the challenge with achievers and the
morning routine is
most of the time you're going through
the motions to just check the box and
feel like i got it done as opposed to
actually getting the feeling the most
important part of a morning routine is
the feeling
so i had
on my tour i had a woman
in albuquerque new mexico
talk about morning routines and she
asked me what mine was and i told her
what mine was but mine doesn't matter
what matters is what you're doing and so
i asked her what what do you do in your
morning routine well the first thing i
do every day is i pray
okay great so you pray and
let me let me ask you an honest question
i need you to be honest right now it's
important for me for you for everybody
here
how many times when you're doing the
prayer when you've done the same prayer
so many times
when you when you're going through the
prayers how many times are you just
saying the words because you know the
words you've memorized them you see them
a million times
how many times you just saying the words
and how many times you actually feel
the deep connection how many times you
actually feel
the power flowing through you
and i forget what the number was it says
40 something like when she actually
feels the power like that's the problem
that's the problem with achievers
you are going through the motions of
your morning routine without without
ever having the feeling
so that you finish in one routine
whether it's ten minutes an hour four
hours however long your morning routine
needs to be
if you don't feel confident alive bold
powerful at the end of your morning
routine then your morning routine isn't
working
i don't care that you checked the box of
having done your prayers or watched that
video the number of people who watch a
video but then you're doing it while
you're making your bed or brushing your
teeth or eating breakfast or whatever
you're not ever really intentional about
watching the video that's great you can
check the box of saying you watch the
video but you didn't get the feeling so
it doesn't matter if you don't feel more
bold powerful confident ready to take on
the day at the end of the morning
routine then your morning routine is
broken and needs to be fixed and it's
either adding something new in
that actually makes you feel that way or
just doing the thing that you already
know works but with more intention
so that's what the woman need to do is
go back and fix some more routine just
with more intention
we often compare ourselves to other
people and their morning routines the
morning routine envy and say well
they're doing it so i should be doing it
like that i should be working out like
the rock four hours a day well that's
probably not what you want to be doing
the key is figuring out what makes you
happy what is the life that you want to
live i understand that your routines
really are set up for you to have the
habits to follow through on success that
you're looking for right success is
habits success is what you do on a daily
basis and your morning routine sets you
up for that so how do we actually then
create a morning routine that works
right let me let me get
practical move from just inspiring to
some tips that you can actually go off
and accomplish
step number one the most important thing
what makes you feel the belief in
yourself
of all the things that you do
that you've tried that you've done what
makes you feel the most belief in
yourself
maybe it's watching a video like this
it's why i design these videos to try to
be a part of your morning routine i'm
honored for anybody who is using these
videos uh
as that so thank you but whether it's
these videos whether it's reading the
book whether it's meditation prayer
working out getting in nature
petting your cats like what is the thing
that makes you feel
belief in yourself
that you're capable of more that today
can be a great day because you're not
don't have the expectations of you
waking up feeling great you won't you're
going to wake up like yes
but what is the thing that you do the
most that has led to you feeling that
love of belief
and you can string together a couple
like when i do this and this and this
and this great
this becomes the seed of your morning
routine
so make that list set number two
is there a sequence to them
what what's the one thing that when you
just start doing that thing it
kick-starts everything else
so that's why making the bed is is
something for a lot of people it's not
that making the bed actually gets you
feel motivated it's that you're the kind
of person who makes the bed and then
it's what happens next is that when you
make the bed you're more likely to then
do the next thing
you're picking something simple as the
first step not because of
it actually doing anything to make you
feel great is that it
makes you do the next step and the next
step and the next step so making your
bread brushing your teeth flossing your
teeth like whatever the thing is
what's the easiest part of the routine
because working out for example working
out on your list that's hard
you might have lots of energy and
excitement now but tomorrow morning
you're gonna wake up and not want to
work out even though you know logically
you know that working out will get you
feeling
expi not expired inspired
hopefully not expired inspired motivated
for the day you feel great after a
workout you don't want to do the work in
the morning
so don't make workout your first thing
something easier that you can fall into
so making the bed
brushing your teeth or there's something
else drinking a glass of water like
you're the kind of person who drinks a
glass of water in the morning so then
you follow through on the next thing and
the next and the next thing so you start
stacking them
right so step number one is you make a
list of the things that make you feel
the belief the courage the motivation
the fire
and you you put that into routine but
step number two is now we're going to
order them
and figure out what is the easiest best
place for me to get started on these
things
so that i can still follow through on
everything else that when i do that one
thing everything else cascades in order
and then step number three is just make
it realistic
make it realistic you can actually do it
one of the biggest problems that people
have with morning routines
is you
create this perfect morning routine that
takes you four hours to do
and it's unrealistic for you to actually
follow through on you'll do it for two
days and then realize wow this is
this is just not happening i'm not i'm
not doing it and what that translates
often is then therefore you suck
because you can't follow the routine
therefore you suck and then the whole
day gets thrown away and the next day
and the next day the next week and next
month nothing ends up happening until
you get inspired for a new morning
routine
right
so the point of trying on other people's
morning routines or getting some ideas
is really just to figure out what works
for you
for example
uh the whole idea of writing in a
journal
journaling just doesn't do it for me
i've tried it a whole bunch of times i
used to feel bad about myself the
journaling didn't work like why does it
work for me what's wrong with me why
why don't i feel better after journaling
my hand gets tired i can't read my own
handwriting i don't know it doesn't
doesn't do anything for me so
after hearing how for how many people
work the work the work the work okay i
committed i'm gonna i'm gonna do
morning pages and i started writing
whatever comes my mind and if i didn't
know what to write i would write i don't
know what to write i'm just reading what
comes to my mind
and having the freedom just to write
that stuff down
but after evaluating i realized this
i feel no better coming out of this
morning routine
than i did going in
and if that's
the result for you it doesn't matter
that evan carmichael does it or mel
robbins does it or garyvee does it or
whoever does it it's not working for you
great you can tweak it test it again try
something different and if it's still
not working if you abandon it and go do
something else and don't feel bad
that it's not working for you
it's fantastic go find a thing that is
just because somebody else is doing it
doesn't mean that it's going to work for
you just because that hat fits
beautifully in somebody else doesn't
mean that it's going to work for you
maybe you shouldn't wear hats ever
right so
step one go back to figuring out what
are all the things that you love doing
that make you feel bold confident alive
the goal of your morning routine again
is to make you feel bold powerful
confident alive ready to take on the day
two you sequence them to figure out
what's the order the how can you start
with the easiest thing that when you do
that thing everything else falls in
place and then three make it realistic
make it realistic that it's something
that you can stick to that you can do
that will fit into your life it doesn't
require super human effort to wake up
and do every day that if you're
traveling or something ends up happening
you can mostly stay consistent on it
right make it realistic for your life
what you're doing
because when you can start your day
with the expectation of not having
energy
right you don't put the fake expectation
of you having to wake up tons of with
tons of energy
but then creating
a structure for yourself
that will bring the energy forward if
you can imagine for the next year wake
up have no energy
do something that will give you energy
to show up more confidently in your life
for the day ahead
imagine how much of a change that will
make in your life you spent a year doing
that waking up little energy waking up
like you normally do
and then after your routine
after doing a couple things whatever
they are for you being bold powerful
confident alive how does your whole life
change how does your business change how
does your career change how do
relationships change all of it because
you chose to show up with intention by
following those three simple steps
you have this behavior pattern where you
get angry you have this behavior pattern
where you snap you have this behavior
pattern where you yell and you get upset
and you make people wrong and you don't
mean to
if you
are somebody who's ever said to yourself
i wish i could stop yelling or i wish i
i i i could just snap i could stop
snapping
this video is absolutely unbelievable
okay and the reason why is i explain
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery
a lot of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they are there because when you were
a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologists and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel
tense or you start to feel stressed out
guess what happens your body remembers
what it was like when you were little to
feel tense and stressed out and what
were the adults doing around you when
you felt that way
they were snapping
they were yelling and now here you are
repeating the pattern
and you don't know why and you feel
guilty
and i'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until i thought holy cow like
i know i don't want to snap at my
husband i know i don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family
why can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern
now all you need to do is basically say
okay i'm going to put a practice in
place that's going to interrupt this
pattern what's the practice well a
really good one is
um
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um
that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun is
you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey
don't take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice
i think that the work that we all have
to do
every single one of us whether you
bulldoze
whether you people please
whether you avoid conflict
whether you're impulsive
whether you
yo-yo your decisions
uh
whatever it is that is your pattern
you know you the the constant trashing
yourself
i think the the the journey of your
whole life
is figuring out how to truly
like
and love yourself here's another massive
insight so i always think about
businesses levels right and i also
realize that is the media landscape or
the um
the particular vertical or industry that
you're building a business in is
changing that is a constant and it's
something that you can't control right
you just cannot control the things that
are happening in the world around us but
you can
always control what you're thinking and
what you're doing in response to it so
all of my work centers inside this gap
between what's happening in your life
and in your work and what your reaction
is to it and how you can't control
the things that are going on around you
but you can always control what your
reaction is and that gap there that's
about five seconds long and you start to
understand that you can change how you
think you can change your habits you can
change how you lead you can pivot and
change even the philosophy of your
company and you can do it through the
decisions that you're making and
managing your reactions you will become
unstoppable so three years three and a
half years ago i got into the speaking
business um
because of the popularity of that tedx
talk that i gave and um that first year
i did um i don't know i think was like
27 speeches the next year
i did 87 last year i did 121 i was the
most female speaker in the world this
year i've kept it at 80 and here's why i
realized just like you may be realizing
in your business whatever your business
is that there are aspects of your
business that you love and that energize
you and there are aspects of your
business that are depleting as hell and
that are old and that are tired and that
if you continue in that lane you're
going to end up 10 years from now in a
place that you don't want to be
it's so important for you to pay
attention to what's energizing you about
the landscape around you and about your
own business because that's the secret
to seeing around corners and so the
corner that i was seeing around is that
as an entrepreneur even though it's
wildly lucrative to do what i do just on
the speaking platform i mean anybody can
do the math on 121 speeches right and
the amount of money that i get paid to
show up and deliver a one-hour talk
and realize there's a lot of money
here's the problem it's a terrible
business because you can't scale it
other than raising your price or raising
the number of times you do it and guess
what else you have to show up
and i can't sell it
so i found myself in a situation where i
had built a multi-million dollar
business
highly
profitable and it was depleting the hell
out of me and i can't really scale it
and i can't sell it
terrible op position to be in in an
entrepreneur so i made a decision
that i you know what was it bo that
actually energizes me about my business
and i answered it with the first
question it's hearing from people
i would rather
answer comments on instagram all day
long then stand in a stadium with 5 000
people in it
i get more from the one to one
connection that's what fuels me and so i
have this light bulb moment paying
attention being clear
that wait a minute i don't want to build
the biggest speaking platform and i
don't want to build a coaching business
i want to build a content company i want
to go back to my roots and build a media
company and so
with that insight i now have to change
right because the kind of business woman
that runs a multi-multi-million dollar
speaking business where it's just you
and your speaking management firm and
your travel folks and your logistics
people and maybe your social media
manager that's who's on the team the
kind of leader that runs that kind of
team is very different than the kind of
leader that is going to grow a hundred
million dollar media company that's
going to syndicate content every single
day that is going to own what she's
doing that's going to build instagram
and facebook and youtube and linkedin as
my personal abc
cnbc fox and this is what i want you to
understand about the story and that is
this in order to get to the next level
in your business you got to decide right
now what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now
because you will not see around the
corner you will not engineer that next
quantum leap unless you personally
change and so one of the reasons why
i've gone from being the most successful
female you know book speaker on the
speaking circuit to launching the number
one book on all of the self-publishing
platform for amazon and one of the most
read books in the world and
selling like gangbusters still is
because i am constantly innovating
myself
i know that i am the single
biggest problem in my company
and if i don't constantly pivot and
evolve how i lead and what i'm focused
on i'm gonna be the blockade and so
you know stop looking at what everybody
else is doing stop micromanaging the
team and ask yourself two years from now
when you think about where you want your
company to be
what habit do you have to change right
now have you ever heard the term
attention economy if you haven't heard
it you're gonna start hearing it a lot
because that's what we live in right now
it means that people and companies make
money when they have your attention
and in the world of internet technology
social media your attention is for sale
and what i want to do in today's
mentoring session is i want to shift
your attitude about how you value your
own attention so got a simple question
for you do you use a phone or a computer
to make money or to improve your life or
does the phone use you
to make money
well look at this
i lifted it up and it started playing a
video check it out it's on facebook
right now every time you are on your
laptop and you go onto a laptop and you
start scrolling mindlessly through
facebook someone else is making money
you ever thought about that like i'm
gonna just scroll through facebook right
now ooh here's a post about yoga tights
i don't need oh and here's something
from buzzfeed about cute group photo of
23 baby pandas trying to make you know
who's making money right now whoever
made this video and so is buzzfeed and
so is facebook but i'm not they're
making money off my attention and as i
keep scrolling oh here's somebody that's
doing something related to the news and
here's another thing ooh chocolate chip
peanut butter cup lasagna cake am i
making money am i improving my life by
no but guess what tasty video is and so
is melissa's southern style kitchen who
sponsored this post
so why am i pointing this out to you
i'm pointing it out to you because the
engineers at facebook the engineers at
every website they they understand
something
they understand that the longer that you
spend on their website or reading their
emails or clicking their stuff the more
money they're gonna make see you and i
are up against a massive amount of
technology and people that want to trick
us into giving them our attention
there's a reason why facebook has an
algorithm where they put things in your
news feed that you like it's because
research shows that you'll actually stay
longer
and how does somebody make money in the
attention economy well they make it by
grabbing your attention
so i want you to consider something
today i want you to be
really mindful about your attention i
want you to be mindful about how you're
using your phone and your computer are
you using it to get ahead
and to make more money and to do the
things that are important to you
or are they using you to make a buck as
you're going about your day just
notice
am i picking up my phone to use it to
improve my life or make my goals happen
or am i picking up my phone and letting
somebody else use me to make money in
order to make it stick go brick by brick
one of the things that's interesting
about having big dreams and big goals is
that oftentimes
the fact that the goals and the dreams
that we have are so big
it makes them uh really really difficult
to achieve because you spend so much
time thinking about how big
the idea or the dream is that you become
paralyzed in the moment around taking
action how do you build a house
by laying
a foundation
brick by brick by brick you go one small
brick at a time and it's exactly the
same thing for your goals by the way so
if you think about where you're at in
this moment and you think about the path
that will take you forward to your big
dreams or to this change that you want
to make and i'm going to use the eating
program as my example because this is
daunting to me
i can come up with a million reasons
right now just like i'm sure you can
come up with a million reasons why you
can't run a marathon you can't do the
singing telegram business you can't take
nature pictures for a living you can't
be more connected to your husband which
is what leanne wants you can't launch
that aromatherapy business i can't
possibly do a structured eating program
with the scale right now because i
travel too much because i'm too busy
because i'm lazy because i'm not
deliberate like my bracelet remember my
my intent bracelet i'm reminding myself
to be deliberate which is probably why
i'm thinking about this program
the path between where i'm at and where
you want to get to is the same it is a
brick path
and it is comprised of a ton of little
bricks that come together to take me
forward and so when you think about a
goal or you think about a dream as a
million little bricks that come together
and lay a path forward
that's the way visually you can break
down your goals and so for me you know
what that one brick could be today it
could be asking chris or my uh
brother-in-law for the phone number of
the person not even making the call
people i'm talking about breaking it
down to one brick so i will get that
phone number and i will write it down in
my little red book or i will write it
down in my five second journal and that
way i will have the number and guess
what the brick is going to be tomorrow
the brick tomorrow is going to be to
call the guy
right and make an appointment and then
the next prick might be to read a little
bit and so the key is going brick by
brick to make it stick because if you
think you can lay the whole path between
where you're at and where you want to go
right now you're nuts so in the ted talk
i cited this this statistic that i had
read uh years ago and that is that a
scientist had calculated the odds of you
and me being born and when you think
about just even the
sexual act of your parents in a lifetime
relationship the number of times they
would actually be intimate the amount of
sperm that go the the odds of one egg
and one sperm and then you throw in then
you throw in the dna
and the uniqueness of your dna structure
some scientists calculated all of those
odds and figured out that the odds of
you being you who you are
born the day that you were born to the
parents that you have with the dna
structure that you have given all the
other variables that could have changed
something
the odds are one in 400 trillion that
you are you and so what that means to me
is that you're meant to be here that
there is a reason why you were born and
the journey of your life is to figure it
out and i think it's actually simple
i think that life is very simple and we
complicate it because we have brains
that can tell stories and
we have um
bodies that can sense danger and so
we over complicate things and the the
purpose of your life is to listen to
your heart and soul
and to follow it
and to express the highest version of
you not the self-doubt not the anxiety
not the fears not the pettiness not the
frustrations but to actually have the
courage to be
fully expressed
as as like
i it sounds stupid but you know as the
as a as a great human being to have the
courage to be kind to have the courage
to be patient to have the courage to
cheer for other people and have the
courage to tune into that wisdom that's
inside of you and lean into it follow
the things that pique your curiosity do
more of that that actually expands your
heart and expands the amount of energy
in your body and slowly but surely if
you align all your decisions and the
things that you spend time on and the
people that you spend time on with the
things that naturally energize you your
whole life will experience a shift if
your friend is facing a problem when you
have to make decisions on behalf of your
friend you tend to
think from multiple perspectives you
think about multiple outcomes and
ultimately you make a much better
decision what they found in research
though is if they put you in the exact
same situation facing the exact same
thing that your friend is you're not
able to be so objective because you're
emotional and you don't make that great
a decision what's the conclusion well
when you make decisions for other people
you're great when we make decisions for
ourselves decisions that can be
emotional we're not so good at it that's
where the power of objectivity comes in
it's the ability to make a decision from
a third party's perspective let me
explain so if you're facing a really
important decision and you can feel
yourself getting emotional maybe you're
thinking about asking for a raise or
changing your career or changing your
major or ending a relationship or
starting a relationship whatever it may
be if it's something that is emotional
for you
you're going to have a hard time
thinking about all the options and
you're going to be really attached
emotionally because maybe you're
concerned about the people who may be
impacted by your decision maybe you're
managing that somebody's gonna be
disappointed or hurt by what you need to
do for you this is when the power of
objectivity is really important pick
somebody that you really admire i mean
it could be somebody like a bill gates
or richard branson or an oprah winfrey
or maybe have a mentor and stop yourself
and ask what would oprah do in this
situation what would richard branson do
in this situation what would your mentor
do in this situation
bringing that level of third party
will yank you
out of your body and your emotions and
it will help you give yourself the
perspective that you need and the
distance from your emotions so that you
can actually assess your options and
make the best decision for you
what would mel do if mel were making the
decision the best decision you know
there's a really interesting example of
somebody who did this in sports and at
the time he actually got a lot of flack
for it it was lebron james now lebron
james as you know played for the
cleveland cavaliers for a really really
long time and he's arguably one of the
best basketball players to ever hit the
nba so he made this announcement that he
was going to leave the cleveland
cavaliers where he had been playing
forever had rabid rabid fans and he was
going to leave them and go to miami
miami
that was the conclusion you woke up with
this morning that was the conclusion i
woke up with this morning
he was giving an interview to espn and
what he said was this he said lebron
james
needs to do what's best for lebron james
now people kind of laughed at him
because it's a funny way to say the
sentence but this guy's really smart he
was leveraging the power of objectivity
mel robbins needs to learn how to do
what's best for mel robbins and you need
to learn how to do what's best for you
here's your new definition of passion
passion is simply
energy that's all that it is okay
passion
is what you feel
when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay i want you
to think about that for a minute i want
you to think about a moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay
and why don't you in the comments tell
me where are you watching from and tell
me about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate
about what you were doing
about where you were about the people
that you are with describe that moment
for me because when you start to
really investigate
passion as energy this is what you're
going to discover those moments when
you're super passionate like i'm sure my
kids would write down when they're doing
community theater with all their friends
i would write down whenever i'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing group
exercise stuff climbing a mountain
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walkathon i'm incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm um doing some sort of
creative project incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm working with our video
team incredibly energized by that
whenever i am
coaching someone or giving advice i am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt
passion now i'm being very deliberate in
how i'm talking this morning on coffee
talk because passion is a huge topic for
so many of you and you've been so
focused on trying to figure out what job
is going to make me
passionate what job is my passion what
is my purpose on the earth i'm gonna
tell you what your purpose on earth is
right now your purpose on earth is to
figure out how to align your life so
that you feel more energized and excited
by it that's it
and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm you're not going to
think your way to passion you can't
think your way to finding something that
you feel in your heart it doesn't work
that way you gotta feel your way into it
it's inside of you do you understand
there's no passion out there somewhere
the passion is in here and so what you
have to do first is you've gotta stop
thinking that you're going to find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you if you're not
facing a breakup personally in your
romantic life you still want to pay
attention because somebody that you care
about might be and this is advice that
you can give to them also breakups uh
happen in your career
um you might be breaking up with a work
situation you might be breaking up with
a friend i know a lot of us are working
hard to draw boundaries and to surround
ourselves with more positive people and
we get questions every day about how you
do that and so breaking up with friends
can be just as traumatic as breaking up
with somebody that is a romantic partner
i have three steps to getting over a
breakup that i'm going to explain in a
minute but first i want to under i want
to explain some research to you to help
you put what you're feeling into context
because what you're going through when
you break up with somebody or you're
broken up with
is you literally
go through withdrawal
i'm not kidding and yeah i'm using the
word withdrawal
where else do you hear the word
withdrawal you hear the word withdrawal
when you hear about people withdrawing
from a drug and that's a lot uh similar
to what you're going through in fact
there was a study done by neuroscientist
lucy brown who found that like drug
abuse romantic love begins with that
euphoric feeling
it's a high right
and when the drug leaves your body or
the romance leaves your life what are
you left with you're left with the
withdrawal which is a craving for it
validate number one
breakfast breakups are painful but they
don't need to lead you broken
so i want you to validate where you're
at it's great that you're asking the
question you got to have a little bit of
compassion for yourself you got to
understand that you're going to be sad
for a while but please don't pour
gasoline on the sadness fire please
please please don't be staring at photos
of your ex please don't be uh putting
his or her social media face right in
front of your face it's gonna make it
worse but definitely validate the
sadness because you're going through a
major change and it might not be a
change that you wanted number two
separate this is the most important part
because the other thing that i don't
think any of us realize is that when you
get broken up with or you break up with
somebody
you don't realize how much of your daily
routine and the habits that you have and
the way that you go about your day was
tied to the person that you're no longer
with and so what you're not only dealing
with is not only missing the person but
your whole
life schedule
may have just been thrown off maybe you
two went to the same gym in the morning
maybe you got a text in the morning from
this person maybe you liked your little
facetime call at work maybe
your friend group became their friend
group and now all of a sudden that
you're broken up because you hung out
with their friends all the time you
don't have that social life anymore and
so it is so important for you to
recognize that you're not only facing
the person being gone but the habits
that marked your day and the other
people that maybe you hung out with and
the things that you did with your time
and the music that you listened to and
the food that you ate that those might
have all been dictated by the person you
were with and those are changing too so
it's important for you to separate your
self i think a lot of women in
particular when we get into a
relationship we tend to lose ourselves
we tend to morph into the person that
we're dating i used to do that all the
time
and so
now we get to the third part
as you start to think about separating
right so you're validating where you're
at you're separating from this person we
need to get to the third part which is
celebrating you
now that you're broken up you have an
opportunity you have an opportunity to
rediscover yourself because i guarantee
you you lost a bit of yourself in that
relationship and so as you think about
the way that the structure of your day
is changed what can you proactively
insert that is a celebration of the
things that you stopped doing
what have you been keeping yourself from
doing because you are in this
relationship that would celebrate you
who are the friends or family members or
colleagues that really lift you up and
how can you find more time to hang out
with them this is a time to celebrate a
moment when you get to rediscover you
one of the most important things when
you're in a situation where the truth
the facts are that there is more on your
plate than one human being can
effectively handle on his or her own
there's a really important
moment where you have to surrender
to the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits
but part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that i want things to
go
and so if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going on it's gonna
make it feel even more overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it so i call this and i think shawn
anchors the one that came up with this
this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin
on a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are
still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter you
believe that you can handle what's on
your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
health diagnosis or you're spinning
because somebody just told you they
don't want to be in a relationship with
you anymore whatever it is that you're
facing that's making you feel
overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very overwhelming life right now
and still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control there's a lot of you
that are running from things
instead of running two things
and that's a huge difference running
from something
versus running to something and so i
want you to think about that for a
minute um
because you don't have to move across
country to change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems
running away from your past have you
ever noticed that when you run
away it tends to follow you
you know i used to uh have this problem
in relationships
and the reason why i had this problem is
because i was a very unhappy person
i didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably four or five years ago i
spent as sad as this is i spent the
first 46 years of my life really not
liking myself really um feeling like i
wasn't a good person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because i had such a low
opinion of myself and it didn't matter
you know i i was guilty not of moving
from one city to another
but i was guilty of moving from one
person to another
that i would literally
get in a relationship i would be in a
relationship for a year and then i would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating now it's just you and the
person in your life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap starts to show up and
that's when you got to start to do the
work and so it was about the year or the
year and a half mark in almost every
single relationship that i would start
getting that itchy feeling and the
reason why i was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so i was no longer distracted by it
and i was going to have to
deal with myself in order to be happy
and so what did i do for years not even
just years decades everybody i'm not i'm
not proud to admit this but i would
literally jump out of one relationship
and into another new one because another
new one would distract me from the fact
that i was an unhappy person
true story
and i think a lot of you who are unhappy
with yourselves are looking to move jobs
or looking to move uh the city that you
live in or you're looking to change your
relationship and the problem isn't where
you live the problem isn't your job the
problem isn't the person that you're
with the problem is how you feel about
yourself
everything that i have done since since
we launched a five-second rulebook was
in reaction to things that were coming
to me
so i never sat out and said hey the five
second rule audiobook has been a
complete uh like record breaker
we clearly have an audio audience let's
go pitch audible audible came to me
which is fantastic
um i never i always dreamt about having
a talk show but i wasn't out pitching
one
sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than a half a
million people that have taken our
courses online
um
was because success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together
remember i was there interviewing you
for it
oh and i was i hated it because what i
discovered is i hate being told what to
do
and so
but that gave me the idea oh we should
do courses ourselves and so this pause
has made me stop and go well what do i
really want to do and
the the truth is i want to go and make
the biggest possible impact that i can
and i want to collaborate with more
people
and
i want to do events
um and i
i don't want to be the ceo i'm a
terrible leader horrible leader
the worst actually um because i'm
amazing at coaching i'm amazing at uh
creating i'm amazing at reacting i'm
terrible at managing people i'm terrible
at managing a project i have add i have
dyslexia
um
i'm a bulldozer when i get anxious
i know we are that's why we
kill each other if we were roommates or
business partners but but i think
understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that i've decided number
one i'm going to consciously create the
next chapter and what is that and i'm
um well i'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you want to advance you want
to do these things you're talking about
yeah
yes
and i want to i want to collaborate more
with a wider audience of people
and i want to build a brand bigger than
mel robbins yep
i don't want it to just be me i want to
build a
platform based business
that uh reaches more people because
here's the thing that has got that got
me through kind of the loss of the talk
show and the way that i think about
things that i hope helps
um if you're listening you're kind of
struggling with something
um
i believe and i went into the talk show
saying this to myself because there's a
99 chance based on the history of people
that have tried to have a daytime talk
show that was going to fail
and
i went in there saying
this i'm not doing this because i expect
to have a successful talk show i'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that i have no regrets and i wouldn't
change a thing but i'm going into this
because i know that there is a skill
a person or an experience i am meant to
have
that will help me
for the next chapter that i can't see
coming you know i love vision boards and
gratitude journaling because they help
me think about what i want and why this
journal it's going to teach you how how
you make your dreams come true i created
this journaling method a couple years
ago because i wanted to stop thinking
about what i wanted and actually make it
happen this is simple it's backed by
science and it's gonna help you make
your dreams come true with just a couple
minutes every morning let me show you
how it works at the very top you write
down the time place and date this simple
trick gets you present and grounded in
the moment now notice this is guilt-free
journaling there are no dates printed so
if you miss a day or two you're not
behind next i'm gonna give you a
superpower this my friend is your inner
compass
learning to read your energy is the
secret to greater passion productivity
and living with more purpose research
from the university of pennsylvania
proves that if you boost your mood in
the morning you actually increase your
productivity all day long these next two
questions will help you take control of
your energy
which changes how your mind perceives
tasks and will make you more confident
about the day ahead and this section
right here it's the secret to having a
great day i want you to identify one
project that matters to you today not
two not three just one when you focus on
just one project a day you leverage the
progress principle it was invented at
the harvard business school and it will
change your life and help you be more
productive so you can make your dreams
come true research proves you get more
done when you focus on less and every
day i want you to focus on just one
thing after you write down your top
project i want you to write down why
this project matters to you when you
know your why science says you're going
to be more inspired and motivated to get
it done
now take that vision and make it your
mission write down one small action that
you're going to take today to move your
dream forward it doesn't matter how
small it is forward is forward according
to research simply using this section of
the journal makes you 76
more likely to go from dreaming to doing
and if you have any other thoughts about
the project here's some extra space to
play around with
when you move from thinking to doing it
may make you feel overwhelmed so let's
change that attitude with a little
gratitude studies prove that grounding
yourself in something that you feel
grateful for will boost your happiness
and your effectiveness finally i want
you to write down your quitting time yup
you heard me right part of your morning
routine should be deciding when you're
gonna stop working at night if you feel
like your wheels are spinning and you
don't get anything done if you have no
balance between work and life if you'd
love to spend more time with your family
and still feel like the most productive
person you know set a quitting time this
is called parkinson's law and it's
rocket fuel for your productivity now
let's go over to the next page everyone
works differently so this page is
designed to work for you if you love
making long to-do lists and checking
things off here's the spot
if you want to plan out your day there's
a timeline on the left and if you need a
place to take notes here's a place where
you put them so there you have it the
five-second journal why do you think
that is in human beings that you know if
things are going bad we won't change
if they're going good we won't change
but it's almost like we need a massive
breakdown near death experience divorce
covid for us to see clearly to start
changing
well there's a really simple answer
patterns
so the thing about all human beings is
that we are pattern
learning machines
and if you feel
stuck or broken i guarantee you while
you feel that way you're not you have a
pattern of behavior or a pattern of
thinking that is broken
and we
need
to be disrupted
because we love our patterns and even
people that i know like
[Applause]
yeah so a lot of people like you may be
listening to lewis and i talking and you
grew up in a super chaotic household
maybe your parents argued all the time
maybe your dad or mom were in and out
maybe there was a lot of fighting maybe
there was actual abuse i don't know what
was going on but it was chaotic as hell
and so as an adult
you have vowed yourself you're not going
to repeat that pattern
but what ends up happening is because as
a little kid
you observed witness absorbed the
pattern of chaos in your nervous system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do i keep
dating these why do i why do i go to
these bosses that treat me like crap
because you don't know
what it feels like to be in a
relationship with either a boss or a
romantic partner or a roommate that is
consistent because for the first 18
years of your life you lived in an
estate called when's the next shoe gonna
drop right
and so wherever it is in your life that
something is broken there is a pattern
that you don't see yet that is making
you continue to stay in a broken
situation now i got fired from a job i
was really excited about
what should i do
excellent question first of all how many
of you have ever been fired from a job
yep
yep i've been fired from a job and let
me tell you something it's a kick in the
teeth doesn't it there is nothing that
feels worse
in the moment than being brought into a
conference room
and being let go and then how bad does
it blow to pack up your stuff and to
leave it stings it is terrible it is
humiliating there is nothing around it
there's nothing around that feeling even
if it's a job that you can't stand
even if it's a job where you've been
looking for another job even if you know
in your heart that this is the biggest
blessing in disguise because you didn't
really like it there
you still want to be the one to rip off
the band-aid don't you you want to be
the one to walk and be like guess what
people i found a different job i'm out
of here so when they beat you to the
punch and they tell you the truth that
this isn't working it's not working for
them it's not working for you and now
it's time for you to leave it is still a
kick in the teeth so i want to be
clear about something
feeling down
feeling embarrassed feeling angry
about how it was handled even if they
handled it in the way that is legal that
is normal
it's normal because
it blows to be rejected and that's
exactly what happens to you emotionally
when you get fired from a job i get that
because boy oh boy have i been there i
have been fired from jobs that i
actually liked i have been fired from
jobs that i needed
and i have been fired from jobs that i
viscerally hated
that i was physically sick going to work
every morning i hated it so much and it
still stinks when you're fired so here's
what i want you to do when you're fired
i want you to really
just relish in how much it stinks
for i don't know an hour
no more than 24 hours you get to milk
this puppy for free you know a free
dinner from your pals at night you get
to milk this and complain about it to
all your friends for 24 hours and then
guess what you gotta stop complaining
about it you gotta stop thinking about
it because you don't have a choice
anymore the job is over and i don't want
you looking back i want you looking
forward now before you look forward
though i want you to do one of the
signature things that we talk about all
the time and what is that
i want you to look for the message in
the mess
what is it that you learned about
yourself
or about
a job or a boss or a
or a kind of work
that you need to make sure you
understand the message of the mess
because when you get the emotion out of
the way
guess what you always see about a job or
a breakup that happens
you always see that that was exactly
what was supposed to happen that that
job that that person that that manager
that that focus that that was holding
you back and you were just too scared to
take the leap you were too worried about
finances you were worried about how it
looked i've been there i get it but you
need to see the message in the mess
because i don't want you to make the
mistake and step into the exact same
thing
or the exact same type of job or the
exact same management situation that
didn't work the first time
because part of the reason why jobs
don't work is it's not a fit
you see people get fired for a lot of
reasons some of the reasons why people
get fired is because the companies are
not doing well and in that case you want
to thank your lucky stars that you're
getting out now so that you can find
something better if it's not a fit
that's a more nuanced reason to get
fired but let me tell you something if
it's not a fit for the company
it wasn't a fit for you either and so
look for the message in the mess what
are you gonna learn about this situation
whether there was a skill gap
and you need to
bring your skills up to speed so that
you're not floundering your next job or
maybe it was a personality gap that you
accepted something that in your heart
you knew wasn't right but you took it
because you had to or because you felt
insecure don't make that mistake again
first of all stop talking about passion
stop talking about launching a business
okay
when you think about it too big
it will paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where
your bills are getting paid and you have
the luxury of being able to try to think
about what you want to do in this next
chapter
here's where i want you to start
i want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
i'm speaking at the energetic women's
conference here in indianapolis today
why am i saying energize
and what do i talk what am i talking
about when i say energize
when i say energizes you i'm asking you
what is it that you're curious about
what is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move
of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that interest you the truth is
passion is just energy
if you're passionate about something it
means you're energized when you do it so
let's reverse engineer this and let's
just
ask yourself a simple question
what are you curious about what
energizes you and if you allow yourself
to explore things that energize you
you my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like
if you're doing something that you're
curious about you're not only going to
enjoy it you're going to be really good
at it because if you like doing it
you'll spend more time doing it which
means you're going to get better at it
why don't you like the size you're all
is it
okay
because i don't believe in losing weight
to be skinny
i believe in getting healthy because of
how it makes you feel yeah so if you
love the size that you are and it's
healthy you should stay the size that
you are
but
if you look in the mirror
and seeing your body the size that it is
gives you evidence to say i'm a piece of
or i'm unworthy what do you say to
yourself when you see yourself in the
mirror
all of those things tell me what is it
let's get it out of your head
and let's bring it to the light because
you know you feel comfortable saying
this to yourself
when you're alone don't you
i want you to say it out loud because
it's it's not
okay to say this stuff to yourself what
do you say to yourself that we're not
going to say anymore i'm disgusting i'm
disgusting what else
the way i live i hate the way that i
look i feel i hate the way that i feel
okay what do you want what do you
deserve to feel good when they walk down
the street yes
yes you do see i think at the heart of
this
i think at the heart of this is a belief
that you don't deserve
to feel that way
so who taught you to feel that that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it holly
maybe
that's usually when it happens
so what i want you to do
is i want you to leave here and what
you're going to go to war against is not
your weight you're going to go to war
against the pattern in your head okay
because the longer you invalidate
yourself the less motivated you're going
to be to change yeah because you're
beating yourself down so we got to start
with not fixing you
you're not broken
you're perfect how you are holly you are
i know you don't feel that way but i
feel that way yeah
it's the pattern up here
that's broken yeah so we just want you
to have a zero tolerance policy for this
like i'm not worth it i don't deserve it
i'm a piece of this um all that no five
four three two one it's like an axe
you got that
and then you're going to come up what
can we say instead
i can do this i do that i can do this
but more important i think it needs to
be more heart-centered i deserve
to feel good yeah i deserve
to have what i want
watch me go get it if you want another
amazing mel robbins video check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there there's new research right out
of harvard that proves that if you take
just one minute
of
an intentional reflection about who
you're going to be today
it changes your level of productivity